[Musique]
à respectivement 24 et 25 ans clara et
armand forment le groupe
agar agar une musique électro propre pop
et dansante où l'on reconnaît
l'influencé des années disco mais aussi
entre autres celle des daft punk au jeu
de l'interview
le duo qui s'élançait fin 2015 se montre
beaucoup moins sage alors agar agar ça
vient d'où c'est une histoire que je
raconte est à peu près 15 fois dans un
interview précédente qu'on a vu le jeu
comme l'a raconté parce que ça fait
plaisir
vous pouvez pas s'appeler armand et
clara parce que c'est un petit peu
laconique
alors du coup je sais pas on a cherché
un petit peu des mots comme c'est un peu
au hasard
moi j'avais sinon qu'il m'était resté
sur la langue agar agar parce que c'est
j'utilisais dans une recette pour
nourrir mes fourmies ce que je fais de
l'élevage de fourmies et du cou du coup
j'ai proposé à clara et puis on est allé
assez vite dessus dans leur duo armand
apporte la touche électro clara les
sonorités rock garage mais les deux
étudiant aux beaux-arts se laisse
volontiers influencé par d'autres formes
de création jeu d inspiration dans la
peinture noire dans les livres
on s'arrête pas là musique pour composer
musicalement leurs chansons écrites par
clara sont inspirés des rêves de la
jeune fille et ne cherche pas à dire
mais plutôt à faire ressentir au public
des émotions
donc ça raconte pas vraiment d'histoire
mais l'ensemble devient très bref
psychédélique
on met des images les unes à côté des
autres et on voit si ça dérange les
émotions intéressante si oui on garde
sinon bon auteur d'un ep de six titres
agar agar devrait prochainement sortir
un album
des débuts donc très prometteur pour ces
artistes qui refuse cependant de se
projeter bon mais pas trop d'avenir
comme tous les jeunes de notre
génération
non c'est pas
l'avenir non non on regarde l'avenir est
aux gens qui se lèvent tôt
sinon je vais revenir à aa on n'est pas
de venir
[Musique]